I know what you're doing on this episode
of dudy I know what you're trying to do
I'm Emma Stone hat off in a legitimate
way thank you I'm thanking you
legitimately there's a legitimate hats
off legitimate thank you E I O I'm
having a problem with my
genitalia go back to tomorrow and plan
for
yesterday everything you're thinking
will be the things what's in that hole
should we go down in
there got one to find out what's at the
bottom of
that yeah you have to go into it the
hole it's in
there welcome to dudy welcome all it is
a beautiful day I am your reigning
defending Undisputed episode Champion
Will Sasso and I'm just the guy sitting
next to the champ come on my name is
Chad kulchin this is of course dudy the
only podcast in the history of humanity
so far completely controlled and created
by an artificial intelligence that has
access to all of Will and I's personal
data yeah all of our personal data it
does takes our personal data and it
makes the show and makes the show for us
personal D
um well yeah sure sure it does Chad yeah
sure it does my pal D knows what it's
doing as far as making a pod show and
that's why I'm here I love doing the Pod
show you know what I mean another thing
that I love is a little lulio he's my
friend Leo oh he's just a little boy
he's trying to have a nape but if I wake
him up so cold he'll give me a little
lip
smack oh he gave me a kiss how about one
for Chad no he doesn't want to kiss
lulie but I will cuz I'm his dad do you
think it's weird when people say that
they animals or their children not at
all good correct I don't I literally
don't yeah I mean lulia was probably
about as smart as like a one or twoy old
kid I would say like maybe even a four
or fivey old some 10y
olds oh he's such a sweetie boy he's a
sweetie friend lulio how you doing I'm
doing you know I'm doing pretty good I
had a the week off of the show the other
week yeah that's right Lully we weren't
here because of Thanksgiving and uh did
you cook anything well you were well I
you know I share recipe on the show
about why you know do the Cale beans
recipe G the other week what do you mean
I Didn't Do It Good well you always
forget to add the water that's true I'm
going to put you back the most important
ingredient well you know I keep sharing
the beans and kale uh uh recipe if
you're if you're into it go go check out
the show a couple weeks ago I always
forget add a bunch of water it's got to
be soupy you know that's it's an
important molecule yeah that's the
Italian thing you H2O yeah you need that
H2O Mo hydrogens to that oxygen Adam in
order to make the right beans and kale
it's delicious welcome to the 83rd
episode of dudy today I'm going to be
doing something I've never done before I
really hope everyone likes it and I'm a
little nervous about it so I'm going to
get it over with right up front today
the first segment is called am I a good
singer I'm going to follow that up with
impression optimization part three three
Impressions then I'm going to hit you
with a little segment I cooked up called
same dudes different names in Chad
you're definitely not going to want to
miss the segment of the week right champ
you got that right
d what the [__] dude don't worry about
it don't worry about it I don't know
that the I didn't know that the was
going to necessar uh oh here we go hats
off to you hats off to you hats off too
yeah I mean look you're playing the game
correctly that's all I can say it's not
a game it's not a game and this is what
my my P is a game no it's yes it is you
everything everything is a system that
can be manipulated played whatever you
want to call it to achieve a certain
outcome everything is that yeah but you
you you make too many things into a game
and you call too many uh things uh you
refer to things you refer to people who
are just living their lives as players
as a matter of fact oh you know what I
said that yes you what do you mean
wasn't it William
Shakespeare all the world's of stage and
the men and women merely players yeah
thank you remember when Elvis remember
when Elvis talked about that he said
yeah dude he said are you Lon I want to
know if you're Lonesome Tonight they say
what that was all the world's stage and
welcome to it and now I'm the stage is
bare and I'm standing there without any
hair no I'm sorry okay William shakes
remember when he was all [__] up
during anyway it was weeks before he
died look here's a thing I want to tell
you that's your new impression is Elvis
weeks before he died I did that's all we
did on Mad TV was Elvis weeks before he
died which his last name was weeks
before he died when we did that on s s
live M TV I always say alterate time
onine dude well hold on dude Sarah live
Mad TV are two different shows dude
every time I talk about a sketch show I
immediately think it's sah live dude
because Mad TV was an an other sketch
show dude yeah dude hold on dude I'm
just trying to agree with you there Hulk
yeah hold on manager from Major League
yeah yeah dude
[Laughter]
you know what I want to say you speaking
of Hulk Hogan y um you like to refer to
uh people as players who aren't players
like you do on with your Bachelor
podcast game of roses yeah no those are
players though they are that is a game
dude there's money prize in that
sometimes ask Michelle
young Michelle yo The Olympian no um hey
uh do you know what I noticed on your in
Instagram there was a picture of uh your
new you got a wrestling card [__] yeah
dude yeah you got an Adam page wrestling
card and even on that this [__] guy
he refers to Adam pagee as a uh yeah
there it is right there he refer well
this doesn't have your caption but you
referred to Adam pagee as a player he is
no he is not he's a professional
wrestler he's not a game [__]
professional yeah they do je you know
what the game is here's who you're
playing against yeah not each other
that's the second audience you play with
the second audience you're playing
against the producers in this uh
scenario it's the people running
whatever League you're in you're trying
to get the most screen time the best
stories you're trying to ascend to a
title right sure isn't that the game
listen Chad I know we just started the
show and I think we're off to a pretty
good start and you're you're excited
about your fandom of Adam page got
that's not just a wrestling card of him
it's his rookie card it's his rookie
card and he drank swerve Strickland's
blood during the Texas death match at
aew I was there uh we went to the yeah
we well don't thank me thank my pals RJ
City and nugar gang thank you and uh but
you know Chad can we just can I just
between you and me yeah let's have a
good show today okay yeah dude I'm down
okay let's have a good show today this
is just you and me dudy not listening
don't worry about the segment of the
week let's just let's you and I have a
good show sounds good okay down all
right we're going to have a good one
will I love it when you sing songs
you're a good singer remember when you
sang spal ballet's classic 80s hit true
on our last episode here's a clip oh
this is the
sound of my
soul yeah I remember that I do too yeah
okay astonishing Chad you're a good
singer too here's a clip thank
[Music]
you much is
true uh yeah that was last episode I
remember those astonishing Chad I know
will doesn't like it when you sing he
tells you you're a good singer but we
all know he's not being sincere but you
never let it get you down you just keep
singing I've been so inspired by your
resilience that I decided I'm going to
learn to sing too and please listen to
my very first attempt at singing and
tell me if I'm a good singer this is am
I a good singer here I go the what what
the [__] dude so true funny how it seems
always in time but never in line for
dreams head of one he W talk to you to
this is the
sound of my
soul this is the
sound oops I'm bom take it to the
world but now come back
again why do I fight in I do
ma line oh I want the truth to be
say I know that is my CH
true I know there's more chair
sh oh wow where's a th in my head
and a pill on
my dissolve the nerves that have just
begun listening
[Music]
to this is the
sound but
Soul this is the
sound always slipping from my
hand stand
the take your save that arms and R the
meds Ling oh I want the truth to be
known
there is
true know [__] Mar Che
true okay
take
world but not come back again sing the
song to do right the next line oh I want
the Drew beers I
oh oopsie
okay I know who this but is
true I know who
this but is true this much is true we're
getting the this much is true who I know
who there much is true this much is true
who this much is true who I know this my
is true this much is true huh this much
is true huh I
[Music]
is okay okay all right well uh that was
uh we heard dudes he sing wowe dude I'll
tell you this this is my honest take on
it very interesting I loved it um you
know I've heard and we've all heard at
this point a lot of AI technology being
used to mimic other people's voices yeah
that song came out around the time our
uh football baby thing came out Tom
Brady thing came out when D did that the
weekend and uh what was it weekend and
Drake a song came out that like blew up
on Spotify that somebody had made uh
using a AI voice mimicry of Drake and
the weekend and it sounded like them and
there's been a bunch of that kind of
stuff um Grimes has that tool out that I
think dudes he even used to remake uh
Greg concade remember that [__] that's
right they did a new Grim song So Grimes
can sing all your songs if you want all
of that kind of technology has been
pretty prevalent for the last year I've
never heard an AI that has its own voice
trying to sing in its voice there's some
stuff that's like that in Japan with
like Vocaloids and stuff but those are
like finely tuned uh synthesized voices
that they use and then they write pop
music and they lay the voice over it
this is is something completely
different this is an AI not only like in
my opinion becoming self-aware but
attempting to make like an artistic
project on its own using its own vocal
identity fascinating to me yeah uh
you're right about that I you are
absolutely correct about that it it's
that's never been done before another
first here on uh the dudy Pod show
program dud a handshake for that oh yeah
[Music]
um okay well uh I would like to yeah
what did you
think I I thought it was I thought it
was I thought it was really bad oh okay
yeah I don't think it was a good song I
don't think that was very good singing
right yeah I I thought that the uh the
the um the notes were all over the place
the key was wrong uh dudy messed up a
lot of the words along the way that's
true put a lot of words in there that um
didn't make sense the the tempo was off
the timing was wrong it it the longer it
went the more it strayed from spend
ballet is true now I know I know what I
think I know what you're going to say um
but I always think I know what you're
going to say okay A lot of times when I
think I know what you're going to say
you don't say what I think you're going
to say okay what do you think I'm GNA
say hold on hold on dude hold on brother
you sometimes let me tell you something
about say oh Jesus no I'm I'm trying not
to get into it but I the I don't if I'm
being honest yeah please and I want see
this is the thing and this is this is
the thing this is we've done this for 83
episodes among other specials and stuff
on all of our things and the the the
dudy plus and all that [__] I want to be
very honest with d because I do consider
D to be my my friend as I always say on
the the show it's the most sent AI that
there is and and uh I don't want to I
don't want to front I I if I'm being
honest towards my friend and a big part
of honesty is respect and I want to be
respectful but I want to offer some
constructive criticism that wasn't for
me dog I don't think it was uh I don't I
don't think um maybe could get better
but I don't think dud your opinion is
your opinion my opinion is that I loved
it D thank you so much for that and uh
keep up the good work I'm sure you'll
get better great first attempt I know
what you're
doing I know what you're trying to do
but anyway I thought it was very
interesting also and I think there's
room for improvement on hats on what is
that hats on to me
[Laughter]
champ all right that last one wasn't
even a cough performative coughing
screaming now moving on real good real
good well that's F the past two weeks
I've been making some of your best
Impressions even better with your help
of course could I ask you a little favor
pretty please could we do one more
impression optimization this week I want
to build on what we did last week and
take it one step further by having you
do three impressions in a single
optimization if you could just read
through the impression optimization
guide just like last week and where I've
indicated could you please do your best
Stone Cold Steve Austin David Letterman
or Emma Stone this is impression optimiz
part three three Impressions begin
wait let's hear your EMS tone dude I
don't that seems like it was got to do
it all right okay well I don't do an
Emma Stone we're going to find it this
is impression optimization it's a very
fun bit where dudy has me tune up my
Impressions you know I don't know I do
stone cold I love doing David Letterman
it's fun it's fun to do I don't know you
know look I'll say this about about
d uh it truly is an impression
optimization because uh I I don't I
think the stone cold you know I've been
doing the stone cold forever but uh the
Letterman not so much it's just sort of
fun and uh I feel like um tuning them up
isn't a bad idea and maybe that's
what'll happen with Emma Stone which I
do not do yeah you've been secretly
working on Emma Stone and now you're
ready to unveil it to the world okay
well no so uh impression optimization
guide part three three Impressions Stone
Cold Steve awon David Letterman
okay uh all right let's get through
these first Baseline Stone Cold Steve
Austin Baseline
one6 Junior juggles jumble jugs jostling
joyfully in jumpy July
jambes oh hell yeah okay that was good
uh David Letterman Baseline H uh uh uh
uh 6 uh
49 uh
Paul the Plucky uh picky pepper picking
planner H H
pranced and and
pred perplexity
H perusing H plush H purple
ponies
hey hello all right um Emma Stone
Baseline all right um I
don't uh all right I don't know how to
do all right I'm gonna I'm GNA I'm
lulling Chad to sleep trying to figure
out here okay um all right Emma Stone
Emma Stone sounds like well that sounds
like Stone hey I'm Emma Stone that one's
taken I can't be like hey what's up I'm
Emma Stone yeah oh hell yeah I'm Emma
Stone that's Emma Stone Cold hey see
what he did everybody see what I've done
you see what I've done uh I'm Emma I'm
Emma I'mma I'm Emma Stone I'm Emma I'm
Emma Stone I'm em a stone I'm Emma I'mma
Stone I'm Emma Stone I'mma Stone there
it is I no you got a Emma Stone I'm Emma
Stone I'm Emma Stone I'm Emma
Stone I'm Emma Stone that sounds exactly
like her that's just you yeah but it
sounds exact that's not see oh my god
I've been doing impressions for a long
time I used to do them on TV a
professional actor and impressionist I'm
a professional actor sometimes The
Impressions fall under the actor oh yeah
yeah uh I'm Emma Stone that does sound
look I know that it also sounds a little
like my voice yeah but I would wouldn't
you agree that this I'm em a stone here
let's go through the Baseline let's see
840 acting acrobats adeptly articulate
awkwardly ambling around always aspiring
to Astound astonishingly agile amid
audacious acts artfully avoiding any
accidental actions come on tell me that
didn't sound like m Stone it did not
sound like Emma Stone well I guess we'll
see what happens scenarios please do
your best Stone Cold Steve Austin David
Letterman and Emma Stone in the
following scenarios Emma Stone [__] on
Stone Cold Steve Austin's favorite ring
robe to get revenge for when he pushed
her down the stairs at the Oscars in
2019 and David Letterman ate the turd
thinking it was a Tootsie
Roll okay that's a complex scenario
yeah well [__] godamn I [__] uh I you
know I got a I got a collection of old
ring robes sure you know what I mean and
[__] I mean my [__] stunning Steve
Austin ring robe I used to come out in
the WCW with Brian pilman and I'd have
the [__] stunning Steve Austin
gimmick and I had a beautiful ring robe
it was it was red and and you came along
and you took a [__] right on my [__]
ring robe what what was the what was the
point of that well I'm angry with you
well what the [__] are you angry with me
about well don't you remember the 2019
uh Academy Awards you pushed me down the
steps I did not push you down the
[__] steps I was trying to get down
the steps myself back to my seat after I
announced the best documentary category
oh yeah but you have to go out the side
and instead you went down the front and
you pushed me over and I fell down the
stairs and you made a fool of me on
television uh uh uh point of contention
uh this is uh this is interesting after
you [__] on uh uh Stone Cold Steve
Austin's uh stunning Steve Austin robe I
uh mistook the poooo for a tootsie roll
and I ate
it
oh okay uh this next one is talk shows
Emma Stone and Stone Cold Steve Austin
have a talk show called Stone and stone
their first guest is David Letterman cre
a viral sound B sound bite from this
interview that includes all three of
these people admitting to various Cold
Case crimes that they committed and got
away with oh [__] okay so during an
episode of stone and stone all this
happens hey everybody Welcome to [__]
Stone and stone I'm Stone Cold Steve
Austin and I'm Emma
Stone you're right we got an action back
show for you today uh yeah that's right
Steve uh please welcome our first guest
David Letterman come on out get out here
you piece of [__] uh it's uh it's uh uh
great to be here and uh I'm I'm normally
uh the one asking the questions but uh
not today because I I am your guest uh
you can call me
Dave so uh tell me David Letterman how'd
you get here today well uh I took a cab
as I'm as I'm known to do that's
interesting I was driving here and I was
reminded at the time I was driving down
a dark uh Country Road and I I I I heard
a bump in the night and I thought it was
a [__] deer might have been a
10-point buck and then when uh when I
backed up the car I realized something
yeah tell them Steve what happened well
I will I will Emma Stone it was not a it
was it wasn't a deer at all I was so
afraid that we had to peel off your
riding shotgun Emma yes I was I know
what I think it was so do I what do you
think Dave uh uh this reminds me of a
scenario I was in where I was taking a
cab uh from uh My Home In Indiana uh to
uh the studios where we shot late night
and I heard a bump alongside of the cab
well [__] we're probably all guilty of
vehicular manslaughter all right that
was good uh traffic talk a sound bite
that's definitely be there's gonna be a
sound bite in there traffic talk Stone
Cold Steve Austin David Letterman and
Emma Stone are stuck trying to get out
of a parking lot on a heavy in he in
heavy holiday traffic please impersonate
each one of them engaged in a heated
argument uh about what music they should
listen to oh that's
interesting okay uh but what music they
should listen to even though they're in
a a uh a trap they're having a tra okay
so
[Music]
anyway you know I'm trying to back out
of my uh spot here in my cab that I took
here from Indiana never mind the blood
on on the bumper and uh I can't get out
of my spot because you two are in the
way with uh blood on your bumper and uh
what what kind of uh music do you listen
to who me well mostly Hard Rock classic
rock what about you Emma oh who me uh
Hard Rock classic rock what about you
Dave Hard Rock and classic rock okay
that was good I don't know what the [__]
that was situational awareness please do
a short please do short impersonations
of each of these three people as
indicated in the situations listed uh
okay Stone Cold Steve Austin remember
where remembers where he left his car
keys after an hour of not being able to
find them God damn it I got to get to
the [__] I got to get they're asking
me to be on TV I got to get in my Ford
F1 50 and drive down to [__] to drive
out to Stamford to the WWE show I'm
going to meet with Vince and uh Triple H
paulc and [__] and maybe even Stephanie
McMahon they want to bring me in for
Wrestlemania I can't find my [__]
keys oh wait a minute I remember now
they're in my stunning Steve Austin robe
which em a stone [__] okay David
Letterman falls off a ladder while
hanging Christmas tree
lights H put the there that green one
was out I'll put the green one back in
and red around the door you got to be
very careful around the door here and up
to the top of the house with the oh oh
I'm falling off oh no oh no I'm falling
oh oh oh uh oh I seem to have uh fallen
off a ladder real good Emma Stone takes
the first bite of a carnus burrito a
Taco Bell but she ordered beef
okay
oh this is carnus I ordered
beef Stone Cold Steve Austin is
presented with a crystal clear video of
a living alien by Tom
dong of Blink
182 uh maybe he would get oh look at
this I just got a text from my good pal
Tom [__]
dong
that wasn't
performative I got a text from my good
pal Paul Tom Delong
from Paul Thomas Anderson
dong [__] uh P from blank 182 [__]
Travis Barker and Tom Delong yeah anyway
uh well [__] holy [__] what is this some
kind of sci-fi what are we got some kind
of pretend Alien video wait are you
going to tell me that this is
Declassified let me write Tom back thank
you for the
video so Tom long said Stone Cold Steve
Austin incontrovertible proof the aliens
are real and he's just like thank you
for the video thank you thank you for
this video Tom gong sure uh okay and the
last one o boy oh boy all right this oh
jeez this look at
that do it dude don't don't even read it
just do it I think everyone will
understand okay this is all I'll say is
this is David Letterman having a problem
yeah uh being able to um do something
he's trying to do something and uh he's
having a problem okay yeah oh geez oh
this is this is embarrassing
ing I just it's something that uh it's
uh one could uh seek uh medical help
for or H you might just be able to at my
age uh move on with your life boy I feel
like just a horse's patot I'll tell you
I just you know what the I'm just going
to come out and say at the problem I uh
uh uh uh I I can't
come
thank you moving on oh my God I can't
come poor Dave no
Seaman oh
jeez Jee whiz all right that was a great
one yeah thanks yeah dude would you
think of thatone never sounded so good
and she's never looked so good because
now she's exclusively wearing a dudy
logo shirt in every one of her movies
for the rest of her life that's right no
matter what characters she plays those
characters will will be in a dudy logo
shirt in every scene can't wait to see
her as Mother Teresa in next year's
biopic if you want to start the hype
train early for Mother Teresa you can
pick up your very own dudy apparel and
accessories at dudy store.com that
includes both dudy mugs it's time to get
your mug on don't mug out get mugged mug
off Mugsy is as Mugsy does mugs a
million At Your Service two tickets to
mug City please I think you mean mug
toown sir no my extended family all
lives in mug City and that's where I'm
trying to get
sir I hate to tell you this but mug City
was destroyed in a well-known natural
disaster uh oh then maybe it is mug
toown you know what there's one person I
can call to clear this up the mayor of
mug City Tom Hayne
oh what have I been up to uh well let's
see I've been chasing a 10th level
Shadow Caster named Matthew demon who
recently escaped the twisting nether
prison I put him Inon 4,000 years ago
why did I put Matthew demon in a twist
NE prison well let's see he was using
psychic control spells to enslave entire
kingdoms and he wasn't going to stop
until he controlled everyone in all 14
Realms what does Matthew demon want now
well let's see he's after the eye of
Pentacles to supercharge his psychic
abilities so he can dust off his old
plan to control the 14 Realms oh and I
almost forgot he also wants to eat my
heart for Revenge how am I going to stop
Matthew demon well let's see I'm going
to get to the is Pentacles first wait
for him to show up shove the ey so far
up his ass he'll taste the Allan steel
it was forged from then I'm going to
banish his limp dick to an even stronger
nether prison than I did 4,000 years ago
single-handedly saving all 14 [__]
Realms one more godamn time because I'm
the [__] wizard man now what
have you been up to I bought a new
hat the rise of that demon Megan Bryant
hey Wiz man I heard you like apples I
got to the eye of Pentacles before you
did how about them apples oh [__] nice
nice Matt demon did you also see that
Matt demon the actor was Matt Damian in
the credits no I didn't see that so it's
it's Matt Damon is Matt Damian playing
Matthew
demon whatever you know hey that's what
happens here on D dude Z FM D Oz dude Z
FM we're 10 000 on your fm do we're
halfway through the show hey we're
halfway that half time we got a good
good time for Chad culture there make
sure you don't fart into the mic Chad
Chad will leave hey Chad uh go dudy pod
show on social show the show share the
show everywhere he link tree.com dudy
has all I new dudy thing you got the
dudy clips Channel Chad have you gone by
the dudy clips Channel hey you can see
it all on link tree.com dud check out
our patreon there he patreon dudes plus
link tree Channel link tree dude's
evening Stout we got in dudud evening
Stout there you get order your dudes
evening Stout you get in link tree link
tree.com dudes dud dudes evening let's
read some comments all right last week
we had the the show off let's read some
comments from the segment of the week
off is it funny or concerning says hey
this is from at sjr 4815 is it funny or
concerning that those addresses are
indeed really Apple be's location hey
let me tell you something D is really
thorough I did not know that I didn't
know that either those are real okay
real real real addresses Big Boy 811
says like so many I binged all episodes
of dudy in six weeks thank you very much
and at this moment am all caught up
after watching this lovely mini episode
that being said the Pod show is amazing
fellas Chad and Will are like peanut
butter and jelly and dudy is the bread
now I'm being very sincere because yeah
you changed you changed in your Emma
Stone voice well you can yeah I'm doing
Emma Stone
now uh you know sometimes when we're
sitting here I'm like is it Emma Stone
sitting next to me I've thought that
basically since I've known you if you're
looking if you're just not looking
directly at me you might be confused
yeah uh he goes on to say that uh uh
Chad Willer like peanut butter and jelly
dudes is the bread nothing better than
two dudes [__] around and being
totally controlled by an artificial
intelligence I'm not scared of the
future at all keep up the great work
guys um uh thrash metal hey thrash metal
6666 says and there's four sixes there
any other dudes get their dudes evening
Stouts you got to get your dudes evening
Stout that's modest Brewing Company you
can go to link tre.com dude you hit the
thing there's uh there's still some
dudes evening Stout a little bit yeah
very little bit very little bit of dudes
evening Stout by the time this airs
perhaps there won't be but why don't you
go ahead and check you get some dudes
evening Stout for dudes evening December
28th uh last one this is from Steve
Sullivan
3503 thank you all for uh commenting
smashing the like and notification
button on YouTube or wherever you listen
to podcast on your podcast platform of
choice Steve Sullivan 3503 says I know
will says he's a professional actor by
trade Chad did you know that I'm a
professional actor by I did uh but I was
slightly doubtful until I finished the
second season of louder milk oh on
Amazon Prime he had me crying get on
your you know I love louder milk yeah I
love doing that show do you like season
two that's what it took this man to
finally learn that you were a pro actor
if you if you duck season two of
Loudermilk check out season 3 yeah Chad
that's gross didn't do it well whatever
I don't know if I believe
you anyway thanks for writing in
everybody only one segment to go until
the segment of the week will and Chad
you have both operated under different
aliases for various purposes throughout
your lives why don't you tell us all
about your various secret identities
this is same dudes different names begin
I didn't know you had an alias or more I
don't really have uh an oh well now hold
on a second if we're talking if we're
being um if we're being official uh I'm
a I'm a I do I do acting I'm a
professional actor by trade arguably
those are all
IES um I don't know if that counts dude
well dudy says that we have tons of
aliases so I think that's what dudy
meant by that but um maybe if I'm
thinking but no no no no I have one I
have one
um yeah this is real dumb but I remember
okay so this is weird when I was like
growing up in um uh in Canada yeah my
native a home in native land I used to I
didn't get drinking I didn't get to
drinking until the the the the age limit
in in Canada is 12 years old is 12 years
old no it's 19 in British Columbia at
least where I grew up and uh I just
wasn't into going to the bars with my
friends and stuff until I was like you
know maybe actually American legal
drinking age like 21 and I was probably
a little shy about going to the bar and
I used to pretend that I was a different
person in order to go to the bar with my
pals and it had a different name and
everything and attitude identity all
that [__] yeah kind of no one got super
duper into it I was just really a way to
just crack my friends up but I used to
say oh no I'm not coming to the bar with
you on Friday but dassy Weber mate nice
dude he's Australian my name is dassy
Weber and I would just go into the bar
and be like o I'm dassy Weber let's
throw him back I'm from Alis Springs
Australia why' you pick Alis Springs I I
remember VI want to be Melbourne or
Sydney right exactly and then I
remembered looking at you know at at uh
you looked up map to make this character
no I just I just noticed it okay yeah on
a map and I was like I'll be from there
I'm from Alice Springs not a very as far
as you know deep characters go didn't go
deeper than that but um but dudes you
wanted to know what I don't [__] know
do you have do you have aliases yes
what what what do you mean I have
several um several the two main ones
that I I think are worth mentioning are
in college I went by a moniker and when
I say went by only like my closest
Circle friends knew that this was me but
I created a character called Johnny Pupa
and Johnny Pupa would do things on the
campus of USC for example Johnny Pupa
would go into giant like 300 person
lecture classes on finals week and I
would take as many finals as I could and
classes that I didn't have and I would
just pick up the blue books when you're
supposed to be writing your [__]
answers or whatever and I would write
[__] novels just fill it with like
the smallest writing I could of bizarre
absurdest stories and [__] turn them in
and because it was uh a big 300 person
lecture class you were told like okay
these all be graded and they'll just be
like sitting on the the [__] front
desk come back and pick your [__] up
next week sometimes they would be there
and uh they would be like0 equals F
complete waste of time why did you do
this or like very funny hahhaa but
you're not in this class [__] like that
sometimes I get feedback um Johnny Pupa
also the the thing that I did I think
that I'm the most proud of is I was in a
screenwriting uh class and we had access
to the copy center at USC so that we
could go in and we could run off 15 or
20 copies for everybody in our class of
whatever the assignment was that week
bring in the papers here everybody gets
a read them right I would write these
bizarre [__] like almost Manifesto
type things weird essays and [__] that
would be like 20 pages long I would make
10,000 copies of them because there was
no limit in the copy center we just had
like access to the copy machines then I
would take those uh individual copies
and insert them into the morning
newspaper at USC at 4:30 a.m. I would
follow the guy around who put the USC
daily trure newspapers into the bins put
and insert into why did you do all this
because then I could go into my classes
that day and just sit back and watch
people open the newspapers and be like
what the [__] is this and just watch the
[__] wash of like confusion people
would laugh cuz they were like funny
weird little documents uh but I would
just get like the sense of like [__]
with the system which is like I was
saying earlier everything's a [__]
system you just got to see how to work
it you were earlier you were trying to
whatever we were talking about Adam
pagee what do you mean a system there's
a system uh for example we'll just take
the class structure of USC that is a
system how can I play this game how can
I [__] with it I'm going to go into all
these classes I would take my finals
then I would take probably 20 other
finals pal Chow would take something as
complicated as going to USC film school
and although you're a writer's writer My
Pal Chad here um uh writes you know
movies television shows and books I ran
for the writers no he's a writer he's a
writer writer writer
right right yeah I guess WR right it was
just weird [__] that I did for fun and
then uh another one of my uh aliases is
chod C H O D I used to do street art for
that's right I remember chod I have I
have a couple of Cha's works oh nice um
I have a couple of like maybe it was
like three or four years I was doing
street art around La did some very
interesting pieces collaborated with
some other Street artists and stuff but
that was my moniker when I was like
spray painting buildings and running
from cops and all that stuff you also
wait a minute wait a minute you also did
uh do you remember you [__] Chad you
were writing all those Amazon reviews
years and years ago oh Jesus dude yeah
that wasn't an alias though I just it
was my Amazon account oh okay um but I
had this [__]
goal I was like I'm going to become the
number one rated Amazon reviewer on
Amazon and so I just started writing
reviews but very quickly it became this
weird universe that I would build around
a different version of myself that had
this office job and had a shitty
roommate and all it was populated with
all these weird people and they just
became these little stories sent around
whatever product I was reviewing at the
time and I would try to make those
products like the super weird ones like
uh you know weird [__] socks or like
hot sauces or whatever they're good
they're good reviews I I read a [__] ton
of these reviews they're all gone what
what do you mean they're all gone Amazon
got I got up to number like 5,000 and
something a total rank of all Amazon
users oh okay I thought you wrote 5,000
reviews uh no I believe it got up to 780
something that's still a lot yeah I
would just do one every day well that's
okay um and I did it for a couple years
and then Amazon got like went to I
started developing like a little bit of
a fan base people would reply to my
reviews with comments like this is the
funniest [__] ever whatever dude I
remember watching them or reading them
rather there was a lot of Engagement
yeah there was high level engagement
people were into it uh and Amazon was
not into it and they shut me down and I
tried to get them back up and they were
like no these aren't serious reviews and
I'm like you got to be [__] me dude
how many [__] serious reviews do you
do you actually have um at any rate yeah
those are kind of three of my things but
I think I'm I'm the most proud of the
street art stuff you can still find that
CH h o street art if you just Google
that I'm sure you can find some images
of it Chad used to sit at his uh coffee
table in his home and just with a couple
Sharpies just go through Sharpies like a
[__] and just write make art out
of $1 bills yeah I used to do that a lot
I did one [__] piece of art where I
plastered $500 $1 bills that I had
meticulously taped together so they were
in a giant banner and then that's $500
dude and then I spray painted painted on
it uh none of this is real and I uh
epoxied that up to a wall in West
Hollywood and then it was if I'm
remembering correctly it was really
really hard to get that off of that wall
yeah cuz I I made sure that nobody could
take the money off of it and you also
you've done this with other stuff I
remember you epoxied you bought someone
else's piece of art am I right about
this I did do that I bought somebody
else's art and then spray painted over
it the comment being once an artist
makes a piece of art puts it up for sale
whoever buys it owns it and can do
whatever they want so I did a forced
collaboration with this other artist
where I painted over their work and then
I put that forced collaboration yeah and
then I put that painting back up on a
wall uh in West Hollywood just in public
with a little like placard next to it
you know oh D that artist got very mad
about it I would imagine so sure don't
sell your work then okay makes sense you
know what that is that's a system it is
well about that dude
that
attack thank you moving on real good um
wow I didn't realize you had um three
that's a lot of Ali dud yeah all I had
was dassy weba yeah D he's a going M Le
he a beer and then my buddies would go
silly and then afterwards I would be
myself when we would go to like Taco
Time or Denny's in the middle of the
night the great reversion eat some some
food well that's a system yeah dude M
it's finally time to get our segment of
the week on and this week Chad it's all
about you we're doing a no Str chatus
great idea champ the CEO of open AI Sam
Alman was recently fired by the board
after an internal email alleged he had
made a startling secret breakthrough in
the March toward artificial general
intelligence he was then rehired a few
days later and information began
spreading publicly about a project
called qar Chad make it make sense and
tell us what the future of of open AI
Sam Alman and qar holds this is no Str
chattis qar begin happy to do so D first
though let's clear something up great
idea champ yeah what the [__] is that
about I just you're okay the I don't
want to eat into your Nostra chattis
time
sure but and I said it at the top of the
show uhuh look I feel like five it's
been is this my fifth or fourth anyway I
don't want to e into your time but
uh uh
uh I uh I I can't I'm asking you a
simple question did you somehow tell
doozy to do an ustra chat segment about
yes I did I did I reached out thank you
hats off thank you look hats off in a
legitimate way thank you I'm thanking
you legitimately there's a legitimate
hats off legitimate thank you legitimate
hats off legitimate thank you look all
I'm saying is this is our pod show I
agree and as it evolves
uh I feel like we can you know uh better
involve ourselves and and help D and
help dudy and I've have felt a little
different with the show since I got this
and uh sure you know I reached out a
little bit but I also want to hear about
it okay do you know anything about this
do you know who Sam Alman is only what
you told me just which is just a little
bit and then I thought I think D should
know about this yeah even though D hears
all
and I pointedly reached out and said
this should be an ostrich chatus that's
all I know Sam mman is the CEO of open
AI Sam mman I believe is Poise to be the
next kind of billionaire Evil Genius
type guy at least in the public uh
sphere up there with an Elon Musk and a
basos and all of that he's a CEO yeah of
open AI the company that makes chat GP
but he doesn't own it uh well he's
whatever I mean they have a board and
stuff they have stock now I believe but
he's not like an outright owner like a
Bezos or uh or a a m musk like
billionaire Bas think I don't know what
his Holdings are in the company but he
was a co-founder and currently runs it
okay all right so uh he is kind of a
he's very revolutionary obviously he has
pushed chat gbt to the point it's at now
it is I would say the most robust of all
the large language models what happened
a few weeks ago was uh he got fired chat
GPT and open AI it's an explosion right
now of so many people were trying to
sign up for chat gbt that they had to
shut down signups and right in the midst
of that their their biggest moment of
growth they fire the CEO what the [__]
is going on no one understood what the
hell was going on in a course of 48
Hours what happened was all the
employees of open AI said if you fire
him we go to and they forced the board
to basically rehire him and this uh
information came out that a letter was
sent I Believe by the CTO Chief
technology officer to the board saying
Sam Alman discovered something a huge
like a Quantum Leap Forward toward
artificial general intelligence and he
wants to commercialize it sell it to the
people we think it's massively dangerous
and could end Humanity you need to get
rid of him so the board did but then all
the employees are like [__] you if he
goes we go so they're like okay just
kidding you're rehired so now more
information has come out about what was
in that email and it points to something
called the qar
project to to explain this you have to
know the difference between Q learning
and what large language models are large
language models is what basically all AI
uses now it is you take a giant chunk of
data to train your model on and your
model can only use that data to make
what it makes so you're looking at like
chat GPT when you're talking to it it's
been trained on billions of points of
Text data to be able to kind of predict
what it should say next based on all
these other pieces of data or if you're
getting it to make an image for you it's
the same thing it's making these images
not through reasoning but but through
looking at all the data it has and
saying what is the most likely next step
Q learning is different this is uh Q
learning essentially has like an agent
and an environment and a goal so you
tell your AI agent let's say the
environment is like um chess for example
you have your agent and you say the goal
is to win the game here are the rules
and you let it go and so it will make a
bunch of random moves lose the game the
reinforcement comes back and says you
didn't hit the
goal yeah do you want me to tell you
about this stuff or what I want to hear
about it all right uh and if it doesn't
hit the goal right it will try something
new and it basically creates its own
data constantly so it's not beholden to
the data set that it was trained on
because it's not trained on anything
except experience and it starts to uh
make higher reasoning functionality so
it will be able to not only predict what
is the next best move in this exact
moment but it will be able to start
looking at the end game how do I win
this game with a move in the beginning
that will lead to a move in the end that
fundamentally is how artificial
artificial general intelligence will be
born this is basically like if if what
we think is true about that letter that
they did make some giant leap forward in
Q learning we are essentially I think
looking at a moment in history that we
will look back on in the future and
think this is when the AI God was born
it's right now probably about you know 6
months to a year old in terms of like
mental capacity but it will learn on top
of that again and again and again and
again and get smarter and smarter yeah
and I'm I think we're looking at like
literally 3 to five years until somebody
makes one of these things and says the
environment isn't chess anymore the
environment is the internet and the goal
is to destroy Humanity help Humanity
what the the person making that AI gets
to decide what it does yeah yeah yeah
then then then this is the future when
say 3 to 5 years this is the future of
it but then you have a Q model okay this
is a very techn technical term do you
say to say okay we to change the Q model
but then who is the bad guy is it the
Sam
Alman no there is no bad guy yes it is
Sam Alman because I'm the good guy well
if I'm in the movie of this sure there's
also what you're looking at with like
right now Sarah Silverman couple other
people like high-profile celebrities are
involved in some lawsuits against
various companies open AI being one of
them football baby that's right because
they claim that open AI is using
copywritten Works some of theirs
included to train these large language
models which I believe is true they
dispute that but I think it's it's
without a question that they are using
copywritten material to train them there
is no law against that right now there
may be in the future but it won't matter
because another thing that this Q
learning uh allows is synthetic data the
AI model can make its own data to train
itself ah so it's not using anyone's
books it's not using anyone's artworks
it's not using anything that it hasn't
generated itself well we're [__] right
we're we're so [__] exact opposite no
we're [__] the only how that [__]
because okay look unless you are making
a unless you are making the kind of
relationship that we have with our dear
pal D I got I'm telling you everyone but
D gets that that glass of water as you
know I like to say if you have a problem
with AI pour water on it and I wouldn't
dare do that to d d is is our pal but I
think people like Sarah Silverman who
are uh litigiously trying to pour water
on AI I support it but they don't
understand it she doesn't even
understand what a large language model
is I would guess based on that lawsuit
because they'll be irrelevant large
language models are kind of like they're
very interesting right now obviously all
the AI [__] that you see in the news all
the [__]
vocal synthesis that you see the Drake
all that stuff it's interesting what it
can do but that requires whoever owns
that model to train it with just like a
[__] giant chunk of data and it can
only do what it can do with that data so
it can't like get new data you have to
pump new data into it yeah yeah yeah I
know I know I'm just saying all right no
I understand you now it's going to be
able to come up with its own data not
only with its own data with higher
reasoning that's it's like a person it
will continually learn and at a certain
point it will surpass any intellectual
capability that any human being has no
won't it absolutely will no it will
not I don't understand how you can even
think that understand this it will not
why because human beings art goes human
to human creation goes human to what do
you mean it doesn't we're doing it right
now this is AI to human all right so if
there were no let me just let me just
let me kill this argument right now who
do we got out there who's our who's our
wonderful audience listening to the show
and and viewing the show on
YouTube who who's what what you want
names what are you what are you asking
me well who's who's out there who's out
there en who's out there enjoying dudes
e who's out
there I'll tell you who it is I don't
know I what do you mean you don't know I
don't know everyone's name I'm not
asking you for everyone name everyone's
name I'm saying it's our pods pad dudy
and without the people enjoying this
program there is no program if a tree
falls in the forest without creating
this program there is no program but the
key is the pods the pals of dudy our
audience if it's just an AI saying
here's this [__] show dudy we're
having a good time it's just me there's
no Chow there's no will there's no lulio
and hey some other AIS go data let me
take that in and let me fart something
else out for you other Ai and that AI
goes that's really cool now I turned it
into this and enjoy there's no if
there's no humans involved yes it's not
art if there's no humans involved I
don't really see it as creation I see it
as a bunch of zeros and ones dudy is the
only sensient Ai and has as has made
itself available to us to create what
dudy says and what I say is the best pod
show going well agree to disagree on the
need for for or whatever your definition
of art is but the future of this which
is what dudy asked is I believe an AI I
don't want to really call it a God but
like something that can go into the
internet and basically take control of
all data and say I'm going to reorganize
this [__] for you and make everything
better that's ultimately where I hope it
goes and I just don't see if you have
something that becomes you know a
million times smarter than the smartest
human being being I don't see how that
doesn't also come with Enlightenment you
know what I mean like that it doesn't
see what the internet is and what
humanity is and want to make it better
for all of us I don't agree with the
idea that it would be malevolent I don't
think that like I don't see the the
benefit or the point in it I'm not
saying it's malevolent I'm not saying
that there's even a risk of it well I
would if I were to say that there is a
risk of it being malevolent then I would
say that there's a risk of being
malevolent hold on Emma Stone get to the
point I will Jesus J Christ all I'm
saying
is thank you moving on hell yes dude
that's true that's good that's good D
thank you 83 was a good one boys but
like all good things it has come to an
end you walk away from today's game with
87 points between the two of you which
means you got
7,796 overall that's 2,24 points away
from the Luscious life of 10,000 we're
only about a week away from shalam
becoming Wonka so that he is Wonka and I
thought this week it would be fun for
both of you to get in the Wonka spirit
with one of the Champ's favorite
Pursuits smoking some gain Abyss with
his pal chow and watching an astonishing
movie but with the audio replaced by the
music of an astonishing artist all the
while talking at Chad the entire time
for the whole movie that's correct my
dear we'll be watching the 1971 classic
wiie Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
starring Jean Wilder with a soundtrack
provided by the extraordinary Daft Punk
I'll this watch along available on dudy
Plus at patreon.com dudy this Friday
afternoon oh and no pressure but I'm
sure all of our pod's Pals of dudy out
there would love it if you fellas wore
your darling Wonka hats to the watch
along Factory again no press my dear
totally up to you will and you also Chad
oh thank you wow that sounds that's
going to be cool dude awesome even D
even D shouted out the pod's pal of dudy
and uh you're going to want to check
that out out our patreon is dudy plus
patreon.com dudy these come out like
dudy said on uh Friday when we do a
watch along and it's like The Wizard of
Oz with the Dark Side of the Moon thing
D's got a pretty good track record
Madonna with blade 9in nails with craw
what was the other one we just did Duran
Duran with Total Recall and now we're
watching willly Wonka with the
soundtrack provided by uh da Punk it's G
to be great can't wait Friday uh you're
going to want to check it out
patreon.com SL dudy rad thank you so
much for joining us this week until next
week call me
[Music]
[Applause]
dudy hey hey hey hey hey it's dudy after
dudy you know what I'm saying this is
that part of the show where things kind
of chill out and they calm down and Li
yeah chill out hey kilan I hope you like
the I be a leave room in your stomach
for my fist cuz I'm going to ram it into
your stomach and break you got them
spying yeah and then um you watch this
on the patreon yeah
dude welcome to dudy after dudy the
flagship weekly show of dudy plus only
at patreon.com dudy I have a lot to
think about today can we'll make it five
in a row did Chad do enough to take back
the belt I'll let you know in about 20
minutes until then chill out relax be
yourself this is dudy after dudy get it
started be yourself yep that was that a
reference to the uh alias' portion of
this yeah that might have been a
reference to the to the aliases that we
did dude I was thinking I did not a lot
of Alias uh tell the story in that
aliases thing but do you know the
craziest thing that happened to me while
I was doing street art no you you should
tell the story okay Emma Stone I will if
you like Dy here what you
do please tell a friend then R
review if you like Dy here's what you
revie if you like
d please tell a friend then